when these music requests come in for
rick and morty i never know what to
expect i i need to know what a frog
planet's
instruments would sound like it's like
an intergalactic race riot but it's a
love story i need a royal march for an
insect species that thinks it's koalas i
write all the music for rick and morty
in fact my name's in the credits hold on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
take for example in season one episode
two i had to score this alien bondage
dream sequence
took a while to figure it out but once i
realized i could use this gregorian
chant as a background element it really
came together
senior the episode getschwifty that
alien band that gets annihilated i did
make it sound like they were playing
instruments from another planet using
only instruments from earth
so i used a bunch of percussion
instruments from all over the world
my favorite song i wrote for rick and
morty was goodbye moon men which is kind
of a david bowie thing and actually if
you listen close you can hear me singing
background vocals here i'll prove it
goodbye
moon man
you say
goodbye moon man
goodbye
[Music]
i left a couple of musical easter eggs
in the show and i'll tell you about one
of them
in season one i wrote a song called
human music and you can hear it in
season two in the lobby of jerry daycare
not everything's purposeful though the
theme song i actually wrote for another
show that didn't get picked up we used
it as temporary music for rick and morty
and everyone liked it so we just decided
to keep it
so i've been with rick and morty since
before the beginning and i've seen all
sorts of music requests come in
and sometimes it gets a little weird but
you know i like weird
and i wouldn't have it any other way
ryan i really want to do a rap about the
flu
and i i can you do it this tempo
[Music]
whatever that tempo is and but give me
five versions